healthcare organizations are
increasingly using cloud platforms to
personalize care
analyze large data sets
enhance research and development
optimize operational costs
and increase their security and privacy
and with hipaa's privacy rule healthcare
entities are also tasked to safeguard
protected health information
google has partnered with many
healthcare organizations over the years
and has consolidated multiple best
practices into a single solution called
a healthcare data engine aka hde which
is aimed at assisting cloud
infrastructure or security engineers set
up a data management layer that is
automated
offer pre-configured data maps and
pipelines to help data engineers and
clinical informaticists spend less time
on things like manual transformation
processes real-time risk scores and
insights optimized for longitudinal
patient records
and has traceability built in in order
to know where data came from and how it
was processed how and why data exists
where it is this is known as provenance
[Music]
[Applause]
setting up your data environment and
designing it for repeatable deployments
in a highly regulated sector can be
challenging
hde offers a pre-built configuration
script that serves as a template to help
build out your cloud resources with all
the necessary parameters and governance
design
it uses a terraform which is a familiar
open source way to define and provide
data center infrastructure using a
declarative configuration language
when projects are deployed successfully
the script will write a yaml file with
all generated fields specified in the
project's config using the generated
fields path attribute
these fields are used to generate
monitoring rules
overall healthcare data engine's
implementation automates the following
for key dev staging and production
environments
the creation of a google cloud folder
and multiple cloud projects provisions
the necessary resources for common
healthcare data use cases as well as the
access rules to manage each
it establishes a collection of audit
locks enables cloud monitoring metrics
and alerts and allows users to create
visualizations to track your resources
and security policies
and if an organization uses an
on-premise or third party identity
platform you can synchronize this user
directory with cloud identity as well as
setup saml 2.0 based single sign-on to
let users access google cloud or any
work app by signing in once and
accessing all their services
next from an information harmonization
perspective data engineers have a
dedicated fully managed jupiter lab web
app running on google cloud ai platform
notebooks
that enables them to convert hl7 v2
messages and proprietary data schemas
that are in csv into fire
this notebook interface serves as an
integrated development tool because it
includes operations such as syntax
highlighting autocompletion of functions
version control integration with git and
a code source repo etc and because it is
connected to your google cloud resources
it can execute distributed data
processing pipelines on dataflow
dataflow is a fully managed streaming
analytics service that minimizes latency
processing time and cost through
autoscaling and batch processing
this is the jupiter lab ide ui in hde we
will open bigquery here on the side
thanks to the ui plugin we now have a
list of tables listed inside of a
bigquery dataset provisioned through the
hde process
these tables have been pre-adjusted with
raw csv data let's take a look at them
note that our goal is to convert this
csv patient data into a fire json
resource
next let's look at our local file system
these are pre-packaged sample mapping
files they are part of hte's jupiter lab
ide this one specifically converts csv
data to fire now let's visit git to the
jupiter demo branch and open the
following file now from this notebook we
will execute these commands in python
code then we will run this pre-built
magic command
when it's done we visit the json that
has been generated
next we run a validation test to our
fire resource and find an error saying
that the patient given name is expected
to be an array
so we will modify the code responsible
for patient data by converting it to an
array and rerun the magic command and
reload the json
and now we have it validated as
successful because it is now valid fire
after this step we perform test mapping
which executes the data transformation
code into a data flow pipeline this link
brings you to the dataflow pipeline
and finally we return to get and look at
the changes and then commit them
data engineers also need traceability of
how data is transformed and created they
need to debug data issues and understand
which pipeline produced what data this
is commonly referred to as provenance
provenance data gets written to google
cloud storage by the various pipelines
for ingestion harmonization or
reconciliation a crown job using cloud
scheduler runs a processing pipeline
that takes this provenance data and
writes it to an operational firestore
provenance links device to input and
outputs document references and fire
resources
for example let's figure out how a
sample patient got created into the fire
file store
by looking at the json we see several
attributes an important one is the id
field which can help us understand the
prominence of the patient data
let's visit the operational fire store
and look at the prominence record by
using the filterable lookup of the
patient id
as we locate it we can investigate in
the elements tab the additional fields
tied to that record
the provenance record combines the
source information as well as the data
of the pipeline that transformed the
source into the target as well as the
target that created the source for
example i can see there are 19 resources
that were created in conjunction with
the patient
some are organizational device location
or message resources
as for the pipeline itself it exists as
a device resource under the agent field
then who in order for me to figure out
the message itself which hl7v2 message
was the source for the data i can go to
the entity what field and here i have a
document reference that points to the
hl7v2 message
let me click into it and show you how
it's structured
when i click content attachment url i
have a pointer to the message in the
hl7v2 store and if i were to do a curl
get request i would retrieve the full
message
and that is an overview of how
prominence works in hte
and there you have it a quick summary on
how you can enable infrastructure and
data specialists
via the healthcare data engine which is
a predefined configuration to get you
started with the necessary cloud
infrastructure and data transformations
with built-in auditability to get
started with some of the underlying
technology that powers hde you will need
to have a google cloud project
if you do not have one i have included a
link to a trial account with free
credits in this video's description
along with other helpful resources
and community if you found this episode
helpful please subscribe to the channel
to get notifications of more healthcare
episodes cheers
[Music]